[Music]
[Music]
Portland
I mean here it not wrong Oregon State
for the city of Portland we just
we are here to check out like a studio
we might
out here we don't know what like the
studios it's the studio that produced or
light blue bow but they're working on
this movie called the
our missing link the invited us to check
out the studio while they're working on
the set yeah their whole set it's so
cool it's so exciting
dude are you excited I'm excited there's
a really cool opportunity today is a
Sunday I think it's supposed to be
tomorrow my name
yeah rebel we go back tomorrow night
sewing it
two days in Portland
Britta chili so we brought our Iceland
gear cuz we've been flying
yeah it's like I just it's like a trial
run of our all our Iceland stuff we're
in the Dunaway it's very hipster here
very appropriate bumper only here for
one day or two days we're coming back on
our own yeah what's the bathroom look
like if mom would I love that tile mmm
that's very you really it's very
military Deanna Oh Deanna is oh there's
two ropes another thing this rope is
perfect for Isaac mom oh yeah and
Isaac's like the king of robes okay you
love wearing robes huh I really don't
walk before in here okay oh that's not
very really I don't know your wallpaper
tastes know me at all even though you're
me yes
all right so first order of business is
watch this what game are we playing
Super Smash Bros Super Smash Bros I see
you in the inflection
what kind of who's your favorite
character and Super Smash Brothers Kirby
Kirby he's so good that's mommy's
favorite like the round people any time
I played a really buff I always win
every time I play Kirby I always win I
hear a challenge in the making here are
we setting that up yeah okay alright so
we are going to try out some of the
Iceland gear are these considered
long-johns Tiff's are like baselayer oh
okay sounds like you're saying bei
Slayer alright so I'm wearing this the
base layer feel like it's kind of
overkill to feel like it's not that cold
here at Portland I want to test out
everything that we bought for Iceland
before we go to Iceland because I don't
want to be out there and be like dang it
it doesn't work or like it's
uncomfortable or whatever it is Oh true
we're testing for the comfort not just
for the heat protection oh for sure
that's the only reason okay you're right
I should test the stuff out the reason
why I'm testing the boots tubes I
brought this today but they're the most
expensive parachute I've ever bought for
myself so I want to make sure that they
don't give me blisters when I'm in
Iceland I want them to give you blisters
now so I could break them in and I'm a
teller nice then you're good to go
you're so smart
all right now to put on the fashionable
part we look like spies we do like and
then we're putting on our like our
costume our uh our undercover disguise
over the spy uniform oh nice very smart
that meanie hold it what I do she's
definitely your son because you guys
look for the same solutions I don't do
these kinds of things
oh I'm lazy and but then I suffer for
because my sleeves all the way up up on
my arm
stupid I'm so stupid no I married you
but you're you're very smart I'm smart
force marry smearing for marrying a
stupid person because stupidity and
smartness is all relative it's fine
they're stupid one that makes you the
smart one the way I do it is put the
base layer first and then I leave it
halfway in my foot and then I put the
pants on and I pull it all the way up
halfway to my foot and then I push it
all the way to my ankle and then I bring
the base layer up and then the pants up
and that's how I do
Oh am I really ready my heart it's
hurting your heart dang it you know what
we're gonna have to buy you bigger jeans
when I go back home but see this is
exactly why we test it before going to
Iceland because after we con murid hit
his closet yes no clothes left high
waters his pants are not that long ago I
thought he was this size obviously is
not this is why we test our clothes
before going to high school
very true he knows he listens to me yeah
you're so smart
good then I'm stuck there helping you
with your sleeve I'm like why do you do
this
good thing you're smart and I get my
extra help alright we are now off to
venture into Portland yeah I like your
boots
you try and show off your expensive
boots we got normal boot I've got common
folk yes all three of our boots are from
my face well I'm excited to see how
these shoes work out for me and I hope
it worth these all happened to your eye
you can't have your dad's house and look
you have a black eye scratch huh yeah I
don't know who did it I don't know when
it happened we rented to myself rust we
paint you're sleeping huh and it didn't
wake you up that or woken me up pretty
crazy cousin you got home I was like
what happened to my baby who did this to
my baby can I love seeing you with your
braces you look so big
who's biggie eleven-year-old phrases he
won't beat you here a bigger old
[Music]
it just happened
let's try to hold a big tent and he was
trying let go I was like wait are you
too old for that now he's like yeah my
dad's my dad's like holding my hand a
lot and I remember getting to the age
where I was just like oh but I remember
specific moment like when that actually
happened it was kind of gradual thing
just now maybe got too old to the
migrants
[Music]
all right so first up first foodstuff in
Portland vrn rasa which is a
mentors by our lips driver Torito
thank you very much and it looks amazing
there's like house-made pasta they take
all the boxes in house
I like being redone
[Music]
that's my right there that spectrums of
egg yolk right there oh so good
those are rhetorical question man
[Applause]
when did you start liking a season yeah
I remember when we first started dating
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah so we were having a conversation
off-camera about the salad we were
eating there's just one like vegetable
like
they're that like yeah I can't figure
out what it was it wasn't sweet
like it wasn't cheese but it looked like
cheese but it was like anyways she eats
it and she was like oh yeah you're not
the foodie
two of us you're the one that's like I
don't know where
yesterday Oh in the fried cheese I was
like oh the bacon so bomb here
see there is not increase that's why
you're the smart one and
I stand corrected on that
[Music]
beat human hair the wig you're talking
about how's your pasta
better than Chef Boyardee is gonna do a
chef boyardee phase right now for his
school lunches every packet if we fight
on my thermal ministers no heat up Chef
Boyardee in the morning to those
canisters
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're at Stumptown and it is a very
popular export of Portland it's a coffee
shop we have a few in la mia bar used to
frequent Stumptown a lot while we were
writing and I figured since we're in
Portland might as well stop in a
Portland based Stumptown this is another
recommendation from Rachael why it was
called town so she said back in the day
when they were trying to create this
city into a city they've chopped down a
whole buncha Street and they would be
nothing but
that's where your travel expert because
I was told the exact same thing and I
forgot it all all right so I said you're
holding mommy's hand again force his
hand in my pocket and I called it out
like talk to Daddy with the digit daddy
the ditch daddy
Oh ditch it daddy oh man baby they're so
mean I think I can't run in these shoes
[Music]
I'm gonna try and drink out of it do you
remember what it's called Thomas and
boom Tom Edison boom
Oh No Benson Benson bubbler the uber
driver was telling us about it to set
that back in the day when it was like
Stumptown that there were a whole bunch
of workers they would just drink beer
Beth Hollywood drink and so this the sky
he decided install water fountains all
over the city so then these workers had
no excuse anymore and they had to drink
water she was saying that the water here
is like the purest and that it is so
good
it's really good it's really fresh
really what
hell I get II know just turning into a
cowboy yeah I got a feel it no I got a
feel of the time like I'm method
drinking the water I drink so much beer
and I got a sober up for work and I'm
gonna drink straight from the Benson
bubbler right now it's pretty good oh
it's really refreshing
I don't know good question
alright so we came back home for a
little bit and oh wait to the hotel we
came back to the hotel for a little bit
and yes I'm holding Isaac I don't know
why he wants to be such a big baby he's
gonna leave this baby everybody has my
face he's so big he's covered up my
whole body like I can't even like turn
around why are you holding on to daddy
like this huh you little weirdo you big
baby with braces look at you
you Braceface holding on you miss being
carried yeah used to force every large
baby do you remember we used to force
everyone to carry him he's still doing
that I know what is this he hasn't done
this in a while that's true you're so
big you're almost to daddy's shoulders
now look at you guys don't we have a
reservation we need to make a slit dang
you got whiplash 1 2 3 foot stayin alive
come on we gotta go eat even though I'm
not hungry I'm so full we are not hungry
at all for this place called bullard
yeah it's supposed to be another another
recommendation by Rachel Thank You
Rachel thank you so much Rachel
and we're about to go eat some
Portlandia food I took off my beanie I
love these boots though that just I just
gotta like point that out money
well-spent you get what you pay for
oh yeah I think that this is a microwave
how cute is that
hey that's a mistake oh yeah in the
cruise you know those are my
you are your own closets oh there's a
microwave no we gotta go ten minutes
did you forget so where we are now we
right now you told them that we were
going to where the hotel fuller it
really cool come
I like how they see this next to window
to it's got some good lighting right now
are you at the worst lady
so what if we ordered the famous fried
chicken that they only serve on Sundays
luckily we're honest good news yeah so I
heard the fried chicken here is a very
very special to the smoked chicken first
before frying it and a half order the
house craft beer so it's paired
perfectly with the fried chicken tonight
Lucy wait I'm gonna find a thigh as my
favorite piece
oh my god there's like smoke barbeque
fried chicken
[Music]
Lycus do you watch a little sneak peak I
think there's always something in these
movies that is something that we haven't
really done before sometimes it's more
noticable I think for me on this movie
what we did with facial animations took
it far beyond anywhere would be before
we used to use a kit system where you'd
have different mouth shapes and you'd
put them together into the computer to
make lines of dialogue but for this
movie everything was bespoke at all the
performances were animators specific to
the shot
[Music]
come pick him up all right pretty heavy
buy something huh yeah so what we use a
technique called replacement animation
and replacement animation is not new
replacement animation has been used in
stop-motion animation since probably the
last 100 hundred ten years or so how we
animate faces is will it'll be popping a
face off cases are held on by magnets
animators will have an entire box of
different facial expressions and they'll
pick another one and they'll drop a pack
on it so on the film missing link we
printed over a hundred and six thousand
different facial expressions the support
material is as I was saying water
soluble it literally will break off you
can rub your hand over it'll wash off
and what you're left with is the actual
plastic 3d printed colored part inside
you're taking out the way that they
rigged it and we learned about the
puppet we learn how they
we learned so much today it's like so
insightful it's pretty crazy I never
knew how much I mean obviously you know
there's a lot of work that goes into
making a movie like this but not like
this like actually getting like a
first-hand from the people that are
actually creating this it's pretty cool
fulness that you're standing in a forest
right now so amazing how much details
they get into it like it's like a real
thing you know what's crazy is I mean we
watch the movie that we pay a little and
so we take the movie for energy having
seen all this after you see these movies
in a different way now
[Music]
I don't want to explore being in like
stop motion stuff now all your toys good
finger acting method legs I use in
movies when someone gets glass around on
yeah oh nice oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]